bella hantise de toutes les mamans
comment retrouver la silhouette après un
accouchement la peau du ventre distendu
les seins qui tombent les vergetures les
lots chi les tranchées le périnée qui
lâche ici pour la majorité d'entre elles
les jours voire les mois après la
grossesse s'avère difficile pour
certains people la récupération post
partum ne semble pas être un problème
bon voila vous m'aviez demandé du coup
dix jours post partum ça donne ça j'ai
encore montré bien moins un petit peu
gonflé émirats ta copine kate middleton
il donna smet quelques jours après leur
accouchement ses stars n'hésitent pas à
s'afficher votre plat alors forcément ça
énerve vous pensez qu'en fait quand on
fait des enfants c'est comme dans les
films qu'on accouche on revient taille
32 taille 34 heureusement certaines
célébrités prône le body positive une
tendance qui consiste à accepter tel que
l'on est et qu'est ce est
il pour reconnaître que ça fait du bien
de voir que même les stars partagent
parfois nos galères
c'est un sujet important de keith a fait
contre aix et beaucoup de femmes qui se
disent pourquoi notamment quand on a vu
aussi la femme du prince william qui est
sorti comme
ouais alors bébé jeu comme tu dis
quelque chose même si tu es très belle
une femme en moyenne prend 11 kg lors de
sa grossesse et 52
32 kg mais moi j'aimerais vraiment
compte des complexes les femmes par
rapport à ça on n'est pas tout les gars
l'on n'a pas la même morphologie pas la
même génétique on n'est pas égale par
rapport à ça alors oui c'est génial moi
j'ai des copines comme vite à amel bent
ou même nabila qui sont juste après leur
accouchement avait un ventre plat moi ça
n'a pas été mon cas et c'est moi qu'on
des complexes les femmes autour de ça on
est pas toutes égales là dessus je vous
donne la parole à des gens tombent
souvent que les femmes disent pardon
mais j'ai beaucoup d'amis femme belle
prendr à 15 kg aux masseurs que
j'embrasse et mais après 10 mais c'est
pas grave j'ai bientôt accoucher oui
mais si tu prends ma kilotonnes enfants
andré vingt trois et demi sinon tu vas
avait un litre d'eau et à porter
atteinte à la personne kg tu vas pas
perdre ton père 5 mio effectivement à la
5 kg 5 kg à la baisse comme maintenant
moi j'ai trois enfants là bas bien sûr
si certaines et la première grossesse
j'ai pris 22 donc effectivement tu
ressortent à 17 kilos à perdre c'est
compliqué de les perdre et compliqué non
non c'est compliqué de les perdre dans
la deuxième grossesse en
mai à temps comment s'explique parce
qu'au-delà de prendre du poids comme on
n'explique pas ce que même une fille qui
prend une star qui prend 12 13 kg pour
épater la couche elle quatre jours après
les a plus ils sont
maintenant probablement que elle a un
coach probablement que d'abord la jeune
fille là ilona elle a 22 ans donc elle a
pas tout à fait la même morphologie
qu'une femme aussi de 35 ou 40 ans elle
a peut-être fait très attention à
récupérer je sais pas combien combien de
temps après a été près cette photo mais
on dit que pour faire un enfant un bébé
il faut neuf mois et que pour retrouver
son corps à peu près il faut aussi neuf
mois je passerai impasse culpabiliser et
puis faut arrêter de regarder
tiendra tous en même temps il ya des
jeunes femmes qui continuera en ceinture
à 8 7 ou 8 mois sont tout mince global a
dû fuir puisque le nôtre c'est après
morphologie tous les ans benoît qu'elle
a très intéressés après je dirais parce
que là ce sujet benoît protéger talent
d'orateur comme ça à l'arrivée un sujet
qui dépeint la grossesse ont dit oui
tout est femme h 1 je pense qu'on n'est
pas tous égaux au niveau du polonais par
exemple non non non écouter deux minutes
moi j'ai suivi la grossesse de ma soeur
donc voilà qui est plutôt de classe
moyenne et je suis en ce moment la cause
la grossesse de capucine à nabeul elle
passe son temps à faire des drainages
lymphatiques affaires des marchands
après je sais qu'elle a une
diététicienne qui lui permit de manger
ce qu'elle veut elle suit dès qu elle
travaille pas toute la journée après
avoir un coach sportif moi ma soeur
quand elles accouchent et quinze jours
après fallait calais où l'ol et le
bulletin dello sport fallait qu'elle
fasse à bouffer par toute la famille
donc avait pas 50 oui mais non loin de
coco et l'époque du groupe ni quand on
est
alors
attention
et on culpabilise dans le sens inverse
moi j'ai pris 8 kilos d'engrais à la
grossesse lui et on m'a dit tu vas y
verrez oui je me suis arrêté de bosser
trois jours avant d'aller accoucher et
on m'a dit pas ce que je voulais pas y
penser on m'a dit tu vas faire une
crevette mais la croma qu'elle faisait
56 cm et 4 kg
gris et j'ai maigri en 48 heures après
et autrefois on avait des techniques qui
coûtait rien qu'on faisait dans les
hôpitaux qu'on ne sait plus on board et
les ventes en mettant des pièces sur le
nombril qui rentrent vite et les femmes
ont retrouvé leur silhouette très vite
même en te fout un barnum de plein de
trucs il écoute beaucoup d'âme et à
raison à liège a lancé un outil d'une
botte ceinture
alors lorient aussi
je dis juste un petit truc un peu plus
polémiques c'est que parfois la question
se pose parce qu'il ya des stars pour
lesquels l'image est tellement
importante notamment parce qu'elles
peuvent être mannequin comme emilie
rattaché au ski ou influence euse plus
ou moins comme ilona smet et c'est que
parfois la photo la crise oppose deux
camps telle date on peut se poser c'est
à moi je laisse supposer
qu'ils aient toutes les légendes des
postes instagram des foyens à qu'ils
disent attention est ce que la photo a
vraiment été prise quand il a été prise
voilà c'est juste pour la petite
polémique histoire ça c'est très bon
becky brewerton on a vu sortir de la
clinique mais pardon parle jamais les
mecs qui grossissent pour
l anacs moi j'ai eu des enfants à chaque
fois j'ai pris non c'est non regardez
j'ai pas perdu
ils prennent le 7 8 9 kilos pendant la
grossesse de leur fille ces psychologies
4 9 kilos à chaque fois way back 9 kg
904 tapeux 30 cycle et j'ai une paire de
jumelles donc une grosse ainsi mais j'ai
bien pris la
voici laurent fontaine j'ai eu une
grosse pour pic est
attendu vers un modèle parce que j'étais
pas d'accord est que les et benoît sûr
si tu as de l'argent l'argent à bon dos
à chaque fois on oui mais toi tu as les
moyens chat ça permet de se faire
épauler de se faire accompagner droit on
peut aussi remettre en question la
motivation de chaque personne parce que
tu as des personnes qui ont dû s'avouer
vaincus qui plus est après une journée
de vouloir le voir à cet art en finale
alors les gens vont dire encore que je
parle de moi mais c'est pour donner une
anecdote du tout alors voilà une
anecdote précise c'est que moi j'avais
la chance de tout avoir à disposition
que ce soit diététiciens coach parte et
pourtant je n'ai pas perdu le point
peut-être que je n'avais pas la
motivation nécessaire je n'avais pas le
courage franchi à l'hérésie dédié des
trucs de grosso fauzy j'ai fini et le
métabolisme la génétique c'est pas vrai
c'est pas toujours une question d'argent
moi j'ai la motivation les bananes aux
mecs passion pour les femmes c'est
toujours un peu lose lose quand on est
enceinte et quand on bosse on est
médiatisé parce que on se rappelle de
rachida dati quand elle avait repris 3
jours après on l'avait vu en photo on
avait dit elle s'occupe pas de son gosse
à la maison dont elle reprend le travail
donc où là la mauvaise mère et après on
se rappelle aussi de luan à luan qui
s'est assis sur une pompe à vélo au cap
a perdu s'est passé c'est non mais c'est
ça qui a perdu ses kilos de grossesse et
c'est donc en fait on culpabilise tout
le temps les femmes c'est à dire que on
avec les enfants on garde les petits
kilos et finalement on a un peu de
shopping à la grossesse c'est grave on
reprend les mêmes et c'est grave on va
retravailler ses gravitation est une
femme c'est trop compliqué non mais
c'est pas d'accord mise et partial
fignon médiatique ou alors on appelle
touré va coûter à ce sujet justement
avec maxime oui la twitter avec annacone
kate middleton on l'a vu oui manificat
we have an après les mêmes techniques
sont révélés elle boit matin midi et
soir fuseau d'un smoothie base de tenez
vous bien spiruline match à épinards
myrtille elle va ou c'est là elles vont
faire
[Applaudissements]
lesquels
ils viennent dire au monde entier enfin
je dirais pas bon en tout cas la france
que kate middleton se vide en permanence
c'est chic pour une reine mondiale elle
est presque sur le trône voilà
des mots
leur corps et leur métier et qui n'ont
pas du tout envie de l'année s'est
encore prononcé qui tient à ce qu'elle
avait fait appel à une mère porteuse
pour pertes et pour porter son enfant
parce qu'elle voulait pas prendre de
kilos en trop elle avait dit que c'était
pour des problèmes de fertilité certes
il est excédé rask est complètement dans
un faux elle ne voulait juste pas a dit
mais son beau corps et âme et conscience
je ne souhaite même pas ma pire ennemie
de tomber ensemble ça vous massacre
ulrich sassano dossier comprend un jour
les femmes 6 à saint palais culpabilité
d'autant que contrairement à ce qu'on
dit c'est plein de deux vergétures à
cause des implants fessiers qu'elle
s'est fait mettre d'accord en tout cas
quand on connait sujet devant lui à
personne mais
alors